hey leute was geht ab und ist willkommen
bei einem neuen video hier mal wieder
auf einem kanal und so ja ich wurde vom
lieben martin getagt und zwar zum tmg
kennt bestimmt also ganz ausgeschrieben
nennt er sich too much information tag
es geht umfragen so too much information
ich weiß nicht ob es jetzt do much
information sind auf jeden fall finde
ich die noch ganz gut ich wollte hier
machen deswegen wenn ich jetzt gar nicht
lange lagern
wir fangen direkt mal an ich wünsche
euch natürlich ganz viel spaß
oh mann
so kommen wir zur ersten frage und die
lautet was hast du gerade an also dass
ihr sohn tanktop das habe ich aus dem
urlaub ich finde das irgendwie ganz cool
und dann noch so eine helle jeans oder
ich denke mal das ist mit jeans keine
ahnung mich jucken oder nicht so
wirklich und dann noch sowohl hausschuhe
damit meine füße schön warm bleiben
hattest du jemals ein schlimmes
beziehungsende also eigentlich kann ich
darauf nur so ganz locker mit nein
antworten weil ich wirklich bin jetzt
mit meiner freundin zusammen und wir
sind halt natürlich immer noch zusammen
so im nächste frage wie groß bist du ich
bin circa 16 14 377 yards ich bin jetzt
nicht so der größte nächste frage
tattoos also ich finde es eigentlich an
sich schon ziemlich cool und deswegen
ich irgendwie so auf einen abend später
mal wenn ich dann 18 oder 20 km
dann lass ich mir auf den am sonntag zu
machen was hier so runtergeht weil die
finde ich am besten mit abstand die
anden sind bisschen überflüssig also ein
tattoo auf jeden fall aber das muss ich
aufpassen dass ich da nicht so von
begeistert bin dass ich mehr und mehr
willen erweitert sie dann ja irgendwann
scheiße aus was ist deine lieblingsband
also ja eigentlich habe ich gar keinen
lieblings wenn ich habe er so mehr so
lieblings deutsch-rapper biker ziemlich
gerne so deutschrap gewöhnt dann von so
benz wäre ich eigentlich immer das was
gerade in ist zumal von denen mal von
denen und rapper mag ich bushido
eigentlich also von rettberg ja den mag
ich zumindest zurzeit von seiner musik
her am liebsten sagen wir mal so
nächste frage lieblingslied mein
lieblingslied ist zurzeit mit abstand
dieses widget oder so
das habe ich irgendwann letztens
gefunden und das habe ich seit drei
tagen irgendwie nur noch so nächste
frage am lieblingszitat ich hab
eigentlich überhaupt kein lieblingszitat
so komische zitate interessieren mich
einfach mal gar nicht weil die eh nicht
dass das hat so an als wärst du hier
innerhalb psychiatrie oder so wenn du
dir sein zitat durchliest habe ich
keines auf jeden fall
lieblingsschauspieler
also ich gucke schon sehr gerne filme
aber ich weiß gar nicht wie die ganzen
schauspieler heißen deswegen keine
ordnung ich fand diesen von
sowohl für ford wie dr weiß sogar wie
der heißt leonardo dicaprio oder so den
fand ich ganz gut ich hoffe der heißt
wirklich keine ahnung will
nächste frage lauter oder leiser musik
also ich höre eigentlich fast nur laut
musikpreise
was bringt ein leiser musik gar nicht so
deswegen laute musik gleise musik ist
gar keine musik ist scheiße so nächste
frage wo gehst du hin wenn du traurig
bist also erstmal vorweg ich bin ein
sehr fröhlicher mensch und wenn ich dann
mal traurig bin dann gehe ich natürlich
auch mein zimmer ruhig sonst hingehen
oder ich gehe joggen keine ordnung aber
ich bin ein kiwi traurig wie lange
brauchst du um zu duschen
ja also ich du schon mal richtig lange
wenn ich dann schon mal unter der dusche
stehe dann ist es so schön angenehm und
dann viertelstunde 20 minuten oder so
und ja die nächste frage ist dann auch
schon wie lange brauchst du dich wie
lange brauchst du um dich morgens fertig
zu machen so rum
ja ich dusche morgens eigentlich nicht
du schon mal abends deswegen hoffe ich
so ungefähr fünf minuten weil ich dann
nur zwei minuten zähne putzen haare hoch
mache und fünf minuten dann greift er zu
locker das heißt ich stehe um das team
auf und macht endlich frühstück über sub
zu schule fertig letztes buch das du
gelesen hast ja das war so ein pflicht
buch für die schule
da hab ich glaube ich habe nicht nur die
zusammenfassung gelesen ich habe
angefangen das zu lesen und dann am ende
die zusammenfassung gelesen damit weil
ich hatte einfach überhaupt keinen bock
mehr
keine ahnung wie das hieß irgendwas mit
seinem toten hund das letzte mal dass du
beleidigt wurde ja moment mal wir hier
und da kriege ich manchmal so fragen von
zehnjährigen kindern die gerade das
internet entdeckt haben
da lautet oder dann dann kommt er so
eine freiheit wie schwul anus wertlos
[ __ ] [ __ ] ich habe mich schon
eingewöhnt also
das kommt eigentlich so eine 2 3 tage
leben muss ich mal sowas lese weißt du
eigentlich ganz normal so welches
instrument spielst du wo ist meine ich
habe eine e gitarre bei dies irgendwie
gerade hier keine harmonie ist auf jeden
fall kann ich die paare spielen letztes
lied das du gesungen hast ja das war auf
jeden fall gerade dieses ripped
allerdings keine ahnung von dem was ist
habe ich immer noch nicht herausgefunden
müsst ihr gleich mal nachgucken
aber ich habe davon seit drei tagen asse
euro so leute und das war's doch leider
schon wieder mit diesem video
beziehungsweise mit diesem tag ich hoffe
ihr habt es bis jetzt durchgehalten und
seid nicht eingeschlafen
auf jeden fall wenn es euch gefallen hat
freue ich mich natürlich übernommen nach
oben wenn es euch nicht ganz so gefallen
hat gibt natürlich auch einfach einen
daumen nach oben
und ja es stimmt ich muss noch leute
denken ja ich denke dann einfach mal
chris von chris day macht mal den tag
wenn der bock hast und dann dann noch
mary von random elliot die beiden auf
jeden fall
ansonsten lag die beschreibung für
weitere links und hinten links geht's
jetzt weiter mit meinem letzten tag das
werde
das war der 20 intime fragen tag und
hier unten rechts mit meinem letzten
video chats auf jeden fall mal ab wenn
ihr bock habt und abonnieren nicht
vergessen wenn ihr nicht mehr verpassen
wollt wir sehen uns dann am wochenende
wieder schöne woche noch bzw
bis samstag 30